[Música]
hace cinco años me estaba yendo al norte
argentino en un ómnibus de larga
distancia
y venía de una semana de mucha presión
laboral y mucho estrés y lo único que
quería era sentarme en ese ómnibus y
relajarme un poco decía bueno no tengo
nada más que hacer la rodilla está acá
voy a relajar y cuando me subí al
ómnibus no creo que me tocó pasillo
habíamos arrancado y yo seguía alterada
serie ansiosa
no podía respirar con normalidad
seguía sintiendo eso que haya sentido
toda la semana
de corazón ni la tierra lo me latía
distinto como si estuviese corriendo que
estaba sentada decía cómo puede ser
tanto decir es el único momento que
tengo para relajarme no tengo nada que
hacer
tengo 12 horas para descansar
y no puedo dejar un cambio
y en ese momento me acuerdo que en
frente mío estaba sentado una madre con
su hijo y el niño se da vuelta se cuelga
de su asiento y me empieza a hablar me
intenta decir algo me muestro muñequito
de pokemon que tenía que creo que luchar
mandar
y a medida que el niño me ha contando
algo yo me doy cuenta de que no le podía
seguir el libro y la conversación el
conocimiento hubiese estado con un delay
y yo no pudiste concentrarme y ni
siquiera sostenerla en la mirada
y adentro mío era como que cada vez
menos aire pasaba mis pulmones no sabía
lo que me estaba pasando porque en mi
mente realmente no estaba conectada no
estaba presente era incapaz de entender
lo que la otra persona me estaba
diciendo y a inge
para
qué es esto que me está pasando
me estoy volviendo loca
no puedo entender una conversación
estoy perdiendo la cabeza
imagínense
lo que yo estaba sintiendo en ese
momento era un principio de ataque de
pánico está en un ómnibus de 12 horas
pensando que estaba por volver loca
y lo que pasó después algo totalmente
inesperado para mí
pero que me lleva a crear algo
para que nadie más tenga que pasar por
algo así como lo que estaba sintiendo yo
pero déjenme contarles
antes de llegar a eso como llegué yo a
esa situación extrema en este ómnibus
había tenido un año de muchísima presión
personal laboral donde todo el tiempo
tenía algún síntoma ansiedad
porque estaba lavando los platos
y empezaba a respirar intranquila le
faltaba el aire por estaba
esperando el colectivo esperando el
ascensor impaciente la taquicardia
tenía un nudo acá que me acompaña a
todos lados una angustia que no sabía
que era eso que me estaba pasando me
curo que está pensé tengo que ir al
cardiólogo me están dando mal el corazón
y por qué
late al ritmo que quiere
me gustaría que vean las fotos que
compartí en mi instagram en mi muro de
interés justo antes de ese viaje en
ómnibus
también puede ver siquiera un píxel que
ayude a compartir lo que en verdad me
estaba pasando lo que en verdad estaba
en mi cabeza todo el tiempo
claro que no el problema no es que yo no
soy no me animaba a compartir mi
angustia en las redes sociales no me
anima a compartir sela a nadie
me animé a hablar de eso con mi familia
ni con mis amigos
y sentía que nadie me entender que tenía
que poder solo aquí va a poder
es como si el algoritmo de las redes
este algoritmo de positivismo de alegría
estoy de traslado a mi vida
con un único mandamiento que era no
compartirás tu sufrimiento porque porque
nadie más está pasando por esto tenéis
que poder solas bus vas a poder solas
eso es la única que está pasando por
esto
y así sea
en esa espiral de soledad de miedo de no
saber qué estaba pasando
y así llegué a deseo news a crear que me
estaba volviendo loca y no saber con
quién hablar a quién acudir que era eso
que estaba sintiendo
en un momento el izquierdo sentía que no
podía más al conductor que el colectivo
yo me tenía que bajar
rompí mi propio mandato y tengo que
poder sola me di media vuelta y elige a
la persona que estaba sentada al lado
mío
podemos hablar
la estoy pasando mal
y te daré una ex compañera de
universidad con la que estábamos
trabajando juntos en este proyecto dicen
lo que hizo
me escucha
me brindó su escucha y para mi poder
pasar mis pensamientos y ponerlos en
palabras poner puede entender lo que
está pasando en que ahí me escuche de
poder
decirles entenderlos y que alguien esté
presente en este momento debo calmarme
me ayudó a bajar un cambio me voy a
volver a respirar a sentir que de vuelta
pero sabe el aire a los pulmones que
volvió a ser rock
y lo más lindo que pasó también en este
colectivo es que mi amiga no sólo me
escuchó sino también se animó a contarme
lo que le estaba pasando a ella que ya
también tenía ansiedad y que incluso
había tenido ataques de pánico varios
imagínense lo que fue para mí en ese
momento sentirme que no estaba sola que
no era la única que era normal lo que me
estaba pasando
entender y sentirme acompañada sólo la
quería molestar sentía que tenía que
poder sola pero no solo no la estaba
molestando al final me estaba tendiendo
un puente
para que ella también me comparta su
sufrimiento las dos nos sentíamos menos
solas y ahí me cayó una ficha
qué es cuántas personas en el mundo
estarían como yo sufriendo en soledad
pensando que lo mejor que pueden hacer
con eso es guardarse lo es decir yo
puedo solo pensando nadie más está
pasando por esto mirando los muros de
todo lo demás y creyendo la vida de los
demás es perfecta yo soy el único que
está pasando por esto voy a poder solo
pretende al algoritmo
y cuando volví de viaje había una
pregunta que no me deja dar vueltas por
la cabeza y era que me hubiese pasado a
mí en ese ómnibus
si no me hubiese animado a hablar de mi
dolor y si no hubiese habido alguien
dispuesto a escucharme en ese mismo
momento
no quiero pensar la verdad
pero esa pregunta cuando empezó el
commit 19 directamente no me dejaba
dormir porque me empieza a imaginar
cuántas personas estarían como yo en ese
ómnibus pero ahora solas en sus casas
con angustia con miedo con tristeza con
incertidumbre creyendo que están solas y
que no lo pueden compartir con nadie
y ahí fue cuando dije yo tengo que hacer
algo con esto todo fue más social
aragonés con esto necesitamos que más
personas conozcan el poder de la empatía
que más personas se entiendan los
sanadores que es compartir tu
sufrimiento y que al final no está solo
que eso te hermana te hace sentir
conectado
y fue por eso que junto a mi pareja que
es counselor decidimos crear una red de
contención emocional para todo el mundo
un canal de whatsapp gratuito
en el que cualquier persona del mundo
que está pasando un momento difícil nos
puede escribir y recibir contención en
este mismo momento por parte de un
voluntario que lo va a escuchar y va a
hacer sentir acompañado que no está solo
en el mismo momento en el que está
sufriendo
hoy me gusta llamarlo el call center del
dolor y aunque quizás los call centers
no estén tan de moda es nuestro explotó
en menos de 24 horas se postularon más
de 2.000 personas para entrenarse la
empatía y ser voluntarios para estar
disponible para cualquiera que lo
necesite
y hoy en día estamos brindando más de
3000 escuchas por semana a personas de
todo el mundo que están animando a
cambiar de algoritmo a decir yo necesito
hablar de esto hay alguien ahí
no saben cuántas personas con ataques de
pánico puede acompañar desde aquí estoy
los poderosos que de haber sido para
ellas en ese momento decir no estoy solo
puedo hablar de esto hay alguien del
otro lado y también para mí y para todos
los que estamos en aquí estoy que
sabemos que podemos ser esa persona en
ese colectivo para alguien todos ustedes
pueden cambiarle la vida a alguien con
un momento de escucha
y lo fascinante es que la mayoría de las
personas que me tengo que acompañar con
ataque de pánico me decían lo mismo lo
mismo que quería yo en ese ómnibus y es
no tengo que nadar esto porque a nadie
más le está pasando
si supieran que una de cada tres
personas sufre un ataque de pánico
pero nadie se está animando hablar de
eso tenemos un tabú para hablar del
ataque pánico de la depresión del
sufrimiento de la tristeza del miedo y
así nos sentimos todos mucho más solos
nunca en la historia de la humanidad
estuvieron los hombres están conectados
como en este mismo momento y nunca nos
sentimos más solos
para que se den una idea
actualmente está en cuántos casos de
comida
145 millones
y saben cuántos casos cuántas personas
con depresión hay en el mundo
300 millones eso significa que hay más
casos de depresión que de kobe
y nadie está hablando de eso es la otra
pandemia la pandemia emocional y una de
las que muy pocos estamos hablando
qué respuesta le estamos dando como
sociedad a eso
la semana pasada me tocó acompañar en
aquí estoy una persona que nos haya
conocido veces un vídeo que subimos en
las redes
justo me tocó acompañarla a mí y cuando
me saludó me dijo
estoy muy angustiada en casa pasándola
mal y estaba viendo vídeos de gatitos en
tick tock hasta que me encontré con el
suyo y decidí escribirles y ahí yo dije
wow
estamos compitiendo con los vídeos de
gatitos
pero que nadie piensa que no me gustan
los vídeos de gatitos porque no es es lo
que quiero decir si me gustan lo que
quiero decir es que esta persona estaba
sufriendo una situación de violencia en
su casa y su forma de sentirse un poco
mejor y de bajar por el muro mirando
vídeos de gatitos hasta qué
y se animó a cambiar de algoritmo a
decir yo necesito hablar de lo que tengo
adentro de lo que me pasa a sacarlo para
afuera te animo a compartir su
sufrimiento hackeo el algoritmo
describió que estoy podía dar al escrito
un amigo lo importante es que ya se
animó a hablar de lo que en verdad le
estaba pasando y yo soñaba con eso y
sueño con eso una sociedad en donde no
sea tabú hablar de mi sufrimiento con
uno algoritmo que me invite a compartir
mi sufrimiento y que me ayude a entender
que no estoy sola en eso y no soy la
única que está pasando por eso
hoy valiente no es el que dice yo puedo
solo hoy valiente
es el que se anima a agarrar el teléfono
y escribirle un amigo estoy pasando mal
podemos hablar
difícil pero también le está tendiendo
un puente a su amigo para que lo cruce
cuando lo necesita
aquí hemos el algoritmo salgamos de
nuestros muros y construyamos puentes
compartiendo lo que en verdad nos pasa
quieres de verdad somos
y digámosle al otro aquí estoy
muchas gracias
[Música]